à
dans ces moments
mais comme voir mais comment fait-on
mois indiqué ouais la mouche dans le
lait j'adore ça mais la mouche dans
l'est c'est dû à michel audiard cdu
michel audiard les sérieux si noté
malheureux ou pas
écoutent oui évidemment j'avais pas
faire ça pendant 15 ans enfin je vois
bien fait encore une saison ou deux
quand même oui oui tu vois elle c'est
sûr mais bien sûr je prends beaucoup de
plaisir à faire cette émission puis koné
long c'est agréable d'être avec lui dire
des canaris sont formidables méconnu du
grand public des moments magiques c'est
un tumulte je me suis tu veux laisser
maintenant attaquer la descente jusqu'au
bout ce que le voir à l'hôpital de temps
en temps mais d'une façon sporadique
la vérité on a un peu triste où il quand
même tu vois c'est normal tu fais passer
pendant huit ans et amon avis en
septembre qu'on va un flipper ouais là
on est cassé on a envie de vacances et
tous m'ont septembre pour keira ne fait
rien dans le frigo va commencer quand
tout le monde va commencer puis qu'on va
se retrouver comme deux cas les gars
seront pas inscrits à l'école en voiture
puis les sens la mouche dans l'être
d'autres aventures nous attendre qu'est
ce que tu veux alors ou pas jean-marie
en 2004 gelé réussi un exploit
vous avez réuni cinquante mille
personnes au stade de france la même
année elle était sacré comique préféré
des français par l'ifop devant laurent
gerra et raymond devos
cela tue aider à vous avez vendu 3
millions du coffret bigard remet le
paquet vous avez joué molière le
bourgeois gentilhomme sur scène
mise en scène par un sac du chien avec
de bonnes critiques et des salles
pleines vous avez enchaîné sur un
tournage
oui et vous revenez le 15 septembre avec
un nouveau spectacle absolument qu'elle
niaque
moi je le suis je ne suis jamais viré
car je suis mon propre blog
ouais t'as la niaque quand même parce
que revenir en septembre avec un oui je
pensais pas que le bourgeon salle est
aussi crevant et puis puis ag ce petit
film tourné maintenant j'ai encore deux
sketches a fait avec lolo donc votre
nouveau siècle où quand tu fais comme ça
je fais ce qui est bien pour les
spectateurs c'est le statu quo n'est
rien on était spectateur comme ça tu
connais que les spectateurs c'est bea va
pourtant alors votre nouveau spectacle
souviens tu l'a jamais fait jamais que
pas essayé pour me faire plaisir c'est
la dernière année non non non
mais je prépare
vous tenez je fais pas il m'a fait
vraiment peur pour l'avenir
moi j'aurais pu faire ça quand même quel
[ __ ] 1-1 laurent avec un doigt humain
même pas je suis même un nom de mon
témoin encore aller il est vraiment dans
ce nouveau spectacle le spectacle de
jean marie bigard s'appelle monde ci va
mieux
oui
mon fils a lieu c était un comédien donc
vous raconter des histoires d'auxi with
his terres du sud ils sont tous là ça va
et ça va aller très loin parce que je
raconte mais mes rêves
ouais et donc les rêves ça n'a pas de
limites de me permettre par exemple
justement je vais dire j'ai dit j'ai
rêvé arrête c'est ma promo new york
non j'ai rêvé j'ai fait un cauchemar
ignoble je devais abattre tout mon
troupeau de chiennes de garde
et tout ça parce qu'il y en avait une
qui avait un peu d'herpès sur les lèvres
un endroit puis je l'avais vu un jeu l'a
soigné moi-même aux le virage acheter
des tubes et puis j'ai dû être dénoncée
par un voisin jaloux le coeur alors les
rires dans mon rêve c'est qu'ils
devaient les abattent d'une balle dans
la chatte et la faune est adroit faut
viser le cri tôt sinon à souffre pendant
des heures
c'est assez mignon de prendre la défense
des chaînes de garderies brèche avec
elle même
ouais mon psy va mieux pour garder mon
psy va mieux en ce moment je vais le
voir trois fois par semaine parce qu'il
n'est pas bien il va me faire une
connerie
au début des années 90 tu as tu as suivi
toi même une thérapie de groupe n'ont
absolument pour de vrai avec le docteur
jal en cas d' absolument non seulement
je les fais mais dans ce spectacle je
vais faire faire une thérapie où
j'enseignais à bah oui il ya un test dia
des tests de déprime par exemple pour
savoir si tu es déprimés ou pas je vais
poser des questions j'en ai les gens
vont répondre par oui ou par non
et après je dirai tout ce qu'on dit oui
à celle là est celle là ils sont pas
bien posément une belle somme si si tout
était à refaire je dirais oui ou non
depuis le début de l'émission qu'il est
depuis le début de ta vie je dirais non
eh ben dis donc c'est bien c'est pas tes
pas débat simard je suis contre la
sédition pièges en tout cas tu dis je
referais bien tout c'est à dire que tout
cas c'est quelle horreur c'est terrible
ça alors c'est lui qui sûr qu'ils sont
planqués évidemment dans le
questionnaire chacun répond et tout donc
ça va être très interactif en sortira
pas indemne de mon spectacle il se fait
que sur mes dix mois la récitation de
mantra et la méditation ne suffit pas tu
es en plus obligés d'aller voir un psy
bah ouais bien sûr tu vas voir c'est
compatible et 2 non seulement c'est non
seulement sont compatibles mais la
psychanalyse qui est elle est bien faite
et qu'un hacker le fait qu'elle qu'elle
te permet d'approcher de toi tu conduis
vers la méditation
a manca blement immanquablement parce
que tu relativises tous situés bien si
tu as bien travaillé sur toi tu risque
plus la grosse déprime c'est existe plus
je relativise quand flat par exemple tu
dis bon j'en prends pas de trop cette
auto chie dessus tu dis j'en prends pas
trop non plus reste au milieu
tu comprends tu fonds publics ma voie du
milieu d'où le nom
d'où les nombreux du milieu à faire une
halte à outils